[Music]
hello and welcome everyone
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are tuning in from thank
you so much for joining us today for
today's panel your journey from stanford
to latin america
my name is jessica chung i'm an
admissions officer at the stanford
graduate school of business and we're so
excited to share a little bit of what
it's like to live and study at the gsb
and the sort of opportunities that the
gsb experience can offer you
especially if you're interested in
living and working in latin america i'm
joined by an awesome
panel of gsb alumni
and before i introduce them i do want to
set the stage for what today's what our
time together today will look like
so today's event will include a brief
introduction to our global community
i'll then introduce you to our panelists
and ask a few
questions
of our panelists before turning over to
the q a box for your questions
feel free to
give the q a box a try you can let us
know where you're tuning in from and
your name we love getting a sense of
who's in the room with us today
and all together we will spend about 55
minutes together
so i'm looking at the q a box hello jose
castellan from
chile hello paula from columbia luis
from peru
hello sarah from chile javier from
mexico
it's so good to see you all here
it's really exciting for us to see all
these names from
around the world i think in some ways
that's kind of what the gsb is like we
have a truly international community
for example our
our community includes 60 regional
alumni clubs all over the world we have
over three over 30 000 gsb alumni
globally and part of the gxp gsb
experience is
extending your network broadening your
um the people in your life and in your
community including people with many
different
perspectives who have
experiences and
um
and and
can bring together
all of those different experiences in
one community so that is i think a great
part of the
stanford gsb experience our community
also includes over 50 clubs and
organizations including regional
interest groups such as the africa
business club the business in india club
the europe club the greater china
business club the latin american student
association and the middle east and
north africa club
so i'd like to next introduce our
panelists um
and i might have them introduce
themselves i do know that alice is
running just a couple minutes late so
hopefully she will join us soon um in
the meantime diego would you like to
introduce yourself first
sure um hi everyone my name is iontana
i'm class of 2018 um
going down my table i
i did my undergrad at williams college
my career was consulting first in
california then nonprofit in south
africa then the gsb uh post gsb i
founded
a non-profit social enterprise called
latin american leadership academy or
lala that is based in media in colombia
but with latin american reach
awesome thank you
um juan manuel would you like to
introduce yourself next of course hello
everybody my name is juan manuel
gonzalez and i graduated from the gsb
uh five years ago it's hard to believe
that the time flies i went to texas a m
university for undergrad
and then post that i went to consulting
i actually stayed
to consult in consulting all the way to
going to the gsb and then i went back to
consulting for two years but then after
that i decided that it was time for me
to
come back to mexico i was doing
consulting in texas and i returned to
mexico five years three years ago to
become the ceo executive director of in
senior port mexico and i currently live
in mexico city
awesome thank you um
so i think we are still
waiting on alice to join us which is
completely fine um before we dive into
questions for our panel i do want to
note that um today is just one one spot
on your journey um your journey can
continue onward at
mystanford.mda where you can
create a profile and a personalized
dashboard uh where you can track your
application
references and clubs at the gsb
um you can find other gsb events and see
more student and alumni stories we have
a really awesome set of events next week
called application week so they're all
about the application process and
helping you get across
the finish line with that application i
will note one more thing we also have a
latin american fee waiver program so if
you are from latin america and you earn
less than four the equivalent of 40 000
us dollars per year you're eligible to
apply to the gsb for free so i do want
to highlight that as an awesome
opportunity
and alice i see you joined us welcome so
glad you're able to make it
no i had a technical problem because i
joined but not as a panelist so i could
hear you and see you and i'm like i'm
here
[Music]
i'm glad i managed to crack the problem
so that was it
awesome
thank you so much for joining us um do
you want to introduce yourself to our
audience
sure so i'm alice i'm mba 216. i was
actually a classmate with with john
manuel
and i uh i am half brazilian half
belgian
so but i currently live in chile i've
been living here ever since i graduated
before the mba i was in finance i did
some consulting and then after the mba i
sort of made a career switch into into
marketing
and now i'm the chief marketing officer
of a bank in chile
so that's briefly my background
awesome thank you all so i'm gonna stop
sharing my screen so you all can see us
a little bit better
and to our attendees please feel free to
start submitting your questions in the q
and a box you can also upvote other
folks questions if you see that
somebody's asked
a question that you're interested in the
answer to
but i'll start with some of the
questions that
i'll start with a few warm-up questions
for a panelist so first i'm curious
why did you decide to get an mba and why
did you decide specifically to get a
stanford mba
can be any other
any order
perfect i'll start uh the main reason
why i started to get an mba from
stanford was because
i wanted to do also
something with education or social
entrepreneurship
and so i actually discovered when i was
doing my research about mba programs
that i stand for allowed to do
allow you to do an mba and a master's in
education at the same time so i d
applied to both and i completed both in
in 2016
but that was one of the main reasons
before i even fell in love with the
culture of this school but as soon as i
started to even in the process of the
admission uh
and the admission process i went to
visit the school and i talked to some
alumni and i really felt that it was a
place where you could be who you were
and you really could follow what you
were passionate about and that was the
main reason my love for education and
management and then the culture and the
people at the school
awesome thank you for that
um should i go next is that okay sure
so for me first of all
i wanted to do an mba
also because i i sort of
felt trapped in the finance consulting
world and i really wanted to to make a
change in my career and so that was one
of the main reasons that i i
started thinking about doing an mba
and then why stanford i was really drawn
by the uh the opportunities not only at
the gsb but also like outside of the gsb
so specifically for me the engineering
school um so the design school the
engineering school i took many classes
at the engineering school and and i
found those really really enriching to
the whole uh like business experience as
well
so and and other than that obviously the
weather and and the good climate like
living in chile uh it's sort of the same
climate in palo alto so that was really
really nice and i was always
laughing with my my friends that were at
harvard for example who had like really
cold winters and we were like at the
swimming pool in february so that was
really really nice
um
my reasons were
somewhat similar to juan maz but
slightly different so
i
i was in south africa i had been outside
of latin america maybe 10 years
i had been working on nonprofits so i
had no savings
and i had very few networks almost
nothing in latin america
and i wanted to embark on this
journey to launch a continental social
enterprise and so on it was just way out
of
proportion for
what i could do at the time
so for me
going
uh
to the gsb for a couple of years to give
myself time to develop the idea develop
myself build networks was really
valuable
[Music]
also because
the program that i wanted to build was
focused on leadership and from my read
of different mba programs i almost saw
the gsb as more of a leadership masters
than a traditional business masters
and it seemed like it was the best one
in the world so i wanted to see from
within what was so good about it uh
to get inspired but i mean about to
develop myself and to become inspired
for what we could build in latin america
so so yeah that's those are a couple of
of the biggest reasons for me
awesome thank you all for sharing that
um
my next question is i'm wondering
what were some of the courses
experiences or resources that you
[Music]
leveraged in pursuing your careers
especially as they relate to pursuing a
career in latin america what was what
were some of the opportunities at the
gsb that
um
that helped you with that
i don't know if juan wants to start but
for me
most most importantly the network
given that um
there are not so many that many students
latin american students at the just be i
mean there are quite a few but you you
end up knowing them all
and so it's really really easy um to
build that work so my husband is also a
gsb alum and and recently he was looking
for a um a country manager for his
company in mexico and like through the
gsb network he he turned out to find one
so actually um
it's it's been really useful and and
that i think is the foremost important
thing of stanford the network and it's
very closely knit so it's really easy to
reach out to someone you really know the
person and it's not a large class and
you end up knowing
maybe 80 85 of your class you really
know them so it's really good uh and
then the second thing i i would say for
me the most instrumental class so far is
is still touchophilia or interpersonal
dynamics i think uh that's a class that
i i still use
daily i actually recently bought the
book that they that they that came out
of the of the course and
and really helped me like recapitulate
and like remember all the concepts and
all the learnings that i had from that
class but i would say for me still the
most valuable class um and it sounds
cliche because most alums say that
but it's really true um yeah
i i will mention uh in my case i knew i
had similar to you i had actually 10
years in the united states when before
starting the the gsb and i knew i wanted
to return to latin america so a lot of
my gxp gsb experiences were around that
so i did a gmx in paraguay
i my gst was in chile and then i led a
gst to panama and honduras so i knew
that i wanted to make sure that i
had the knowledge of the business
culture
anything that i needed to do in latin
america because most of my professional
life had been in the united states so i
took advantage of those two years to
make sure that i reconnected with latin
america and like i also would like to
highlight what ali say and
is the network a i pretty much
know
all of the latin american people in my
class and you get to meet the ones
above the ones below but in particular
since i knew that i wanted to return in
mexico to mexico i i took the time to
create and build those strong
relationships and most of my job that i
do right now is fundraising and thanks
to the network of the gsb i'm able to
achieve the goals that i need to do
for fundraising and teach for mexico so
i definitely uh the ca is a place where
you will create these awesome
relationships that are very intimate so
whenever you reach out to them they'll
say yes to whatever you're asking of uh
of them so those are the things that i
would like to highlight
and just for our audience there are a
couple of acronyms used throughout there
so gmix
and i think gst
global management immersion experience
which is for four weeks you get to go
and work in a place country where you
have never worked
and a gst and global study trip
the one that i did in chile was as a
participant so it's a trip in which you
go for a full week
to talk to business people to
people from the cultural aspect to
actually know what it's like to do
business in that country and you also as
a second year you can lead at trips and
it is awesome because you get to talk to
ex-presidents current presidents when
you're looking to organize these
meetings uh but it was i definitely
recommend them because it truly allows
you to see even though it's only seven
seven or eight days
we'd really pack those experiences and i
definitely recommend them
so thank you
um
i don't think i took any classes
that were
focused on latin america um
i would definitely encourage
the alumni network
uh professors
and i remember the animations officer
told me that they were the
the most underutilized assets at the gsb
um
most professors there are top of their
industry they're total badasses
um
so
professors alums
um
almost like any class that touches on
interpersonal skills communication
skills relationship building all of that
ended up being super helpful uh to build
my own networks
um
and for me also the entrepreneurship
classes like startup garage um
really helped me shift
my internal chip from
i have this idea that i want to build in
the world
to a more lean startup design thinking
approach that was a lot more humble a
lot more experimental
a lot more listening
involved that i think ultimately ended
up too loud being
light american leadership academy being
a much more innovative leaner scalable
venture than it would have been
without me internalizing these ideas and
i'm also writing in the chat a lot more
on these classes
oh awesome thank you
um
thank you all so much for your
reflection so far
um there is a question in the chat that
i won't elevate um so one of our
attendees asks how would you describe
the gsb community and culture
i think it's interesting that i think
all three of you reflected on
community network
juan manuel i think you used the word
like intimate community i'm wondering
what is it about the gsb
the community or the culture that
creates the sense of closeness and this
willingness to help
other folks in the
gsb community and network
i will start by let's go ahead
i will start by saying that um
i think the gsb does a very good job on
identifying very good well-rounded human
beings
that are trying to really live through
the model of the gsb change lives change
organizations and change the world
so i think what allowed me to connect
with many of my classmates was that even
though we might not have shared this
similar passion in my case it was
education what i'm passionate about but
we were so truly passionate about
something in particular but to make the
world a better place not just to make
ourselves
uh better or just to feel our ego it was
more like that and then
it also helps that the class size is not
so big
so
i mean i pretty much throughout the two
years i definitely can identify every
single classmate by face and name maybe
of course i would like if i tell you
that i develop friendships with the 400
but
with about 200 of them i definitely
created some connections and then if we
go to smaller like
about 10 15 of them that continue to be
some of my closest
uh people that i talked even to this day
that i message that we have some calls
that we organize trips and it has to do
with that aspect that i think we are
truly there to find uh things or tools
that are gonna help us to improve the
world and that is even though it might
be in a different area we share that
passion to make the world a better place
i i would say and just add that i agree
fully agree with what juan manuel says i
think just added i think the location
also helps like the fact that you're not
in the middle of a big city uh you're
close to san francisco but you're like
45 minutes away an hour away so and sort
of that sort of really we used to joke
that there was this like magnetic thing
around the stand for campus that didn't
allow you to get out of it because like
you feel so attracted and just
everything you need is there and so it
really generates this not only with the
gsb students but also you you end up
getting to know like you might for
example i lived in escondido village
which is like the family place
uh and i really got to know my neighbors
and until this day i still have contact
with most of them and so
i would say that makes it like sort of a
a really tight community i think the
location really helps um because i've
seen i've visited other other locations
and other schools that you have this if
it's inserted in the city it's less
community right um so i think that helps
as well
um super quickly i'd say
uh
[Music]
there seem to be genuine care
for each other's development so people
talk about
uh cultural feedback
big culture of vulnerability like for a
lot of people it's it's kind of weird
so
but it can be beautiful so make sure
that you're comfortable
entering a space where people will be
digging into
emotions and feelings and
be very curious to talk about that a lot
and yeah i would echo what honma said
i think a higher than average percentage
of people who
who really want to make a difference in
the world um you know
awesome thank you all yeah i have heard
before i think on another panel um
somebody said that it wasn't unusual to
see your see a classmate cry maybe like
once or twice a week um
and
maybe that's not true of your experience
maybe it's just only true of her
experience
and i think some of that starts not the
crying necessarily but being vulnerable
trying to
sort of figure out how to express your
authentic self kind of starts in the
application process like one of our
essay questions is what matters most to
you and why and
i've heard from so many students and
alumni that that process of
reflecting and and that process of
introspection kind of starts with the
application process
so i'm turning back to the q a box and
thank you to our attendees who are
submitting really fabulous questions um
i see that there are a couple questions
about msx and i'm going to defer to the
msx
admissions team if you have questions
about their
admissions process i'm going to defer to
them please feel free to reach out to
them
but there was one question about
intending to stay in the u.s after the
program and wondering um if they would
be able to find work opportunities in
the u.s
juan manuel you mentioned that you
stayed
in the u.s for a period of time after
getting your mba can you say a little
bit about what that
process was like um any support or
resources that you found helpful at the
gsb
yeah i think
many of my classmates even some of my
mexican classmates like half there were
nine of us and half of us
stay in the united states for like one
or two years after the gsb and of course
there is the support of helping you get
a job with these places that are gonna
get you the visa
to be able to stay in the united states
so that is definitely support also from
the cartwheel center if you need advice
or what is the process uh to be able to
stay but there is opportunity and like i
have some even some of them are still
there so
you want to stay a bit longer uh of
course but of course uh me being an
advocate for latin america i want you to
come back don't stay in the united
states for too long something that i
would like to highlight is
i saw the question about the return on
investment
definitely i think that our talent
having the privilege of going to the gsb
is way more valuable than in latin
america than if you stay in the united
states there is many more gsbr's in the
united states if you come here
you are the top of the top so you're
going to be able to get
those positions that are very well paid
so the return will be there but like
like me i'm deviating
deviating
from the question but like i am a person
that spent 14 years in the united the
united states but i can tell you that
our talent is more needed here than
there so please if you stay only do it
for a few years and then come back and
do something for our countries
i think also muhammad to that point like
i think
well i know for the brazilians because i
was really good friends with all of them
and and like i would say only two of
them have stayed
most of them stayed a few years after
and then most of them are back in brazil
now and then two of them have stayed and
that's maybe because they married with
americans
or or with other internationals um and i
would say as well for the chileans i
think the three of the chileans well two
of them well one is back now in the us
but he came back for a long time he did
an entrepreneurship and then he went
back so i would say most of them at some
point come back uh so i i think it's
because
you get more opportunities here than
than perhaps in the in the us but not
for everyone like there's cases that get
a lot of opportunities in the us as well
so i think it's it's a personal
journey
awesome thank you both
um
there's a question
that i think picks up on some of the
some of the themes that you all are
drawing out
um
jose asks how has the gsb community
supported your career success
and juan manuel well you met you brought
up the
other question earlier about return on
investment and sort of the access to
distinctive opportunities that you might
only find at the gsb so um yeah how how
is the gsb community
even after you've graduated continue to
support your career success
i'll let diego start with this one
because i feel like i'm always starting
um
for me it's been hugely valuable i mean
i'm sure there
there may have been other ways to get
connected but
for example our main funder
we met because of a professor's
introduction
another main funder was a professor
um
the first foundation that supported us
was the introduction by a professor
then
the first latin american donors we found
have mostly been somehow connected to
the gsb so all that has been super
helpful um
[Music]
uh also
uh i mean other introductions not just
donor connected uh
have happened faster through
through gsb alumni for sure
um maybe it's in part because uh
i mean it's not a large community right
like so
definitely other mbas will have larger
alumni communities in latin america
i don't know if they would be as
responsive i i would just go to their
info sessions and ask them
in my case it has been
fairly responsive
not everyone but most
um so yeah
uh in my case i i
i won't say that the community has
helped me directly like i would say
indirectly because i have
they helped me like with thought
processes like what change should i make
now but i think i've made some pretty
big switches in my career even after the
mba so i started at ab imbev in like
their zx ventures which is like their
their
new product development or how you want
to call it
and then i switched i became the cmo of
a tech startup and knowing nothing about
tech and i have never worked in tech and
i became the cmo of a tech startup and i
think part of the reason i could make
that change
was because of like the stanford
credibility and and the fact that
stanford has a lot uh has a focus on
tech
and knows a lot about um you get these
entrepreneurship uh classes and all
these vibes when you're there and i
think that's the main reason that i was
able to actually make that switch uh
that fast so i think um it gives you
sort of credibility uh and that really
helps during your career especially if
you want to make some different changes
um
and then the community helps in in
different ways for example for them it
was like fundraising for me it's more
like opening opportunities and and
thinking helping think through like what
should be my next move in my career and
that really has helped me um getting
having that support network to talk
about those things
i don't have anything else to add
so we can take more questions
all right thank you
um
oh there are a bunch of great questions
in here
uh there are a couple that
okay i'm gonna bring together a couple
questions that are in here
um a few of our attendees are wondering
what
was your most memorable experience
during the during your mba experience
so most memorable experience or
the most valuable impact on you
personally and professionally from your
mba experience
most memorable i'll say talk talk is a
tradition at the gsb where
every monday or wednesday depending on
the class that you are either whether
your first or second year two classmates
uh share their life story
and it can be about anything that they
decide and for me i
was able to share where i came from my
love for education and everything
and remembering
seeing so many people just curious to
know who i was as a person and then also
thinking of the other side listening to
all the stories of my classmates and uh
it makes you realize how human we are of
course we are all human but like when
you
when you go to those talks you people
that you never expected to have gone
through very hard challenges they
actually went to very difficult
challenges people that you never knew
that were like
very good at a certain sport or like
very good about a certain subject that
is the most memorable
and the most impact is definitely like i
will also highlight what it was
has been said about leadership
uh one class that has had the most
impact in my career since i started in
singapore mexico has been
managing growing enterprises
like
this class i never thought that i would
have to deal with writing a press
release i never thought that i would
have to deal with drama between founders
and board members i never thought like
many things at this class
i learned
now i'm looking back in retrospect and
be like
literally they teach you the many of the
pain points of a growing enterprise and
prepare you for
for what you're going to be facing as a
leader of an organization
yeah was my my most memorable experience
uh is the i did an exchange with the
tsinghua university in china
and i had never been to china and i
think we went there and i think it was
in october or november it was really
really cold and i ended up uh having a
bronchitis and i ended up in a hospital
in china it was it was crazy but like
that experience was for me and and
studying at the university of tsinghua
doing that was also really really
impactful for me and then when the
tsinghua students came back to stanford
and we got to
like
they stayed at our houses it was really
really a really cool program i really
enjoyed that
and then personally i think another
really memorable experience for me was
was just um i i went to the gsb with my
daughter so she was three when we got to
the gsb and it was just me and her and i
think uh yeah we spent two years there
and seeing her grow up and and i mean i
grew up because she was five when we
left but i grow through that process and
living there with her
and and getting seeing her really
involved in like the stand for the gsb
life was really uh impactful and to this
day i think it really had a major impact
on her and her development
so yeah
that's beautiful thanks for sure
uh
for me
uh
i remember i mean it wasn't just one
moment but i remember
being struck by
how consistent
the theories the philosophies the
evidence were all in in the direction of
a particular kind of leadership
that fortunately was connected to just
be a better person listen be humble
try to do what's best for your team your
customers
when you're negotiating it's not about
crushing it's about you know finding
a
creative win-win for both parties
and so on so
i think only one class
uh
talked more about like ooh by the way
don't forget about power uh and it's a
classical path to power that is kind of
like the dark side
class but everything else was very much
aligned
and for me that was helpful because
there's so many books out there so many
gurus so many podcasts and articles
that
for me
the consistency
from very successful very thoughtful
people
back to also by research that there is
this consistent narrative um it just
helped me cut through so much noise
and
echoing what paul maneuver was saying
i found that the hardest challenges in
this line of work have been
interpersonal and intra-personal
so i've i've enjoyed the gsv's emphasis
that there's a lot of classes you can
take on both i wouldn't say there's just
like the one class
and those have been the most impactful
post gsb
awesome thank you all for sharing those
reflections
there are a few questions as well about
[Music]
what surprised you all about the gsb
what
do you
what did you maybe not know that you
learned during your time or what did you
not know about the gsb that you learned
during your time there
um
yeah we'll start there what surprised
you about the gsb
or even something that you wish you had
known
prior to your experience
um
[Music]
i said it earlier but i wish i had known
just the caliber of some of the
professors um
[Music]
that
yeah i mean there's just so much wisdom
and uh
networks and resources behind
each one of them and if you try to get
to know them outside of the gsp there's
a thousand steps you have to get through
that you can just take their class you
can take them out for coffee and so on
so just
investing a little bit more time not
just reading the class reviews or not
just reading the class description but
also trying to be like who are these
professors and
trying to
uh to build those personal connections
with them and that they are responsive
they will grab coffee with you if you're
their student mostly
um
i found that surprising and i wish i had
been even more
intentional about that and carved more
time for that
i wish i would have known how intense it
is because it is a very i mean we are
talking from the place that we finish
and we love it and everything but like
be prepared for a place where uh if you
want to make your experience more
enjoyable it took me the first quarter
to realize that
you cannot do
everything that
that all the opportunities out there
like this these classes can be
challenging if you make them challenging
the social events everything is like a
place where
uh
i mean for me it helped me that i did
know what i wanted to do post the gsb
however i recommend you that it gets
some ideas of what you want to get out
of it because you know you're going to
confront yourself with many
opportunities and you're not gonna be
able to do all of them so
you're gonna get anxiety stress and fomo
and all of that so i wish i would have
known that
you need to
get there with more like uh focus
otherwise it can be stressful
i think from you the thing that most
surprised me is that and and they they
say it very graphically in at stanford
in the beginning is that um we're all
ducks like we look calm on the surface
but on the like under the water we're
all like pedaling really really fast and
i think um what most surprised me was
that
that first quarter i struggled a lot
like just as common especially with my
daughter and dealing with all the the
like intellectual challenge like i would
get home and actually be be happy to be
able to talk to a three-year-old for
like two hours not having to say
anything smart you know um and i think
that once you realize that everyone's in
the same boat like most people are
pedaling underwater um you sort of relax
and i think that that's the thing that
most surprised me like realizing that
most people were actually
the same you know and and i think that
surprised me
[Music]
thank you for that
um
i guess diego you kind of touched on
what you would have done differently
based on what you know now juan manuel
and and alice are there is there
anything that you would have done
differently based on some of those
things that surprised you about the gsb
or or otherwise
i only started taking courses outside of
the gsb um in the second year
i maybe would have done it like one
quarter earlier because i really like uh
engineering and coding and things like
that and so i ended up uh not being able
to do one
coding class that i wanted to do
um but i think that's the only thing
that i would have done differently like
look outside of the box really make sure
that i'm
taking in all of the stanford because
the gsb is immersed in a bigger stanford
campus that i want to um that's that's
the one thing that i think i would have
done differently
i think i'm gonna i call what diego say
about professors i didn't develop
any strong relationships with professors
i focus more on classmates so looking
back and talking to some classmates that
are very good friends with professors
even after they have graduated i wish
that i would have identified there is
only a couple that i can still keep in
touch but i i talk to some of my
classmates that are like with five
different professors and they even
go have coffee still or when the
professor comes to mexico they they hang
out so i wish i would have taken
advantage of that great resource that is
the professors at the gsb
thanks thank you all for sharing those
reflections
um we have a couple questions about
leadership style as well
some of our attendees are curious how
your leadership style changed due to the
due to your experience at the gsb
um as well as how
how did
that
affect your
um i mean how did that affect your
leadership in this very
um unprecedented time in covid if if it
did
yeah i would say for me i mean
i think it did affect my leadership
style i think before that i didn't
really have that much leadership
experience like i was in consulting i
was still like a senior uh analyst so i
i was just leading two or three people
and then after that i really felt like i
was ready to to get more to lead bigger
teams
and i think the most important thing for
me like take away from gsb has been
to really uh meet people where they are
like understand that you have different
persons in your team and they all did
want different things and and really try
to understand what are their personal
motivations what is really important to
them and try to
yeah like really meet their development
where they want to go
and give them those those challenges
that they really are interested in
because if they're internally motivated
they are much more productive and you
don't need to worry about entertaining
them about like pay well you still need
to worry about that obviously but i mean
it's easier it's just much easier and
you build a better team
also the other thing i think i would say
is uh one of the classes i had i don't
remember which one but it talked about
if you're going to make changes in your
team and i'm talking about when you take
on a new team when you change jobs make
them once and cut deep and cut cut once
i think that was what they said i think
it was managing growing enterprise i
don't remember which wish it was but um
and i think that's one of the takeaways
i've had as well like
when you have to make difficult
decisions
make them once and make them
so that you don't mess up the team so
that people don't start worrying like
okay am i gonna be next is it is this it
or not um so i think that's that's been
one of my my big takeaways and i would
say in covet that helped uh to a certain
extent where in my previous job
at the end of my previous job we had to
let go some people so um
i would say that was really useful and
post covert i think one of the things
that uh really helps me now is that i
try to innovate when i do meetings with
my team like let's not use teams again
let's not use zoom again let's use this
other app that we can do or let's do
something different i send them coffees
i do and i think that it's constant
innovation is something that i really
got from from stanford
that's awesome
for me it has been it's
i wanted to be perfect before the gsb
for everything that i do when i was in
consulting and i worry too much about
this perfection
and after the years being a more like
emotional perfection never showing if i
was breaking inside or anything because
the gsb that has changed a lot i'm
definitely a more vulnerable leader i'm
not scared to say i don't know i'm not
scared
to ask for help
and kobe this became so helpful like i
don't think i will have survived in the
education sector especially in the
communities where we work without asking
for help to my own teams to my board to
tell them
um i need more money like i'm
like the organization is in danger so
like
like being able to express yourself and
be vulnerable um
for me it has been how my leadership
style has changed a lot and is in
similar to at least i know that people
also have the vulnerabilities and if
they see the leader opening up you're
gonna know what is happening and what is
happening behind
their mind and it's gonna help you to
identify how can you support them to
even become better at the job so
definitely that's the the way that the
gsb changed me and was like it's okay to
be vulnerable it's okay to show your
emotions and
i'm not afraid anymore even if people
some people
that are like me like i was before that
thought that showing emotions maybe was
a sign of weakness i don't care because
maybe that's not the type of leader that
i want to create a strong relationship
so i want to create with relationships
with people that are truly
vulnerable and humane so that has helped
me a lot to create even like now
very good partnerships in the
organization because
we connect with those people
more
um
i love all those points um
i was also thinking that
i think a lot of what happens with the
gsb is that you get exposed to a lot of
these these ideas tools and so on and
then you just have to keep practicing
them the rest of your lives like it's
not not gonna come out
like
i know kung fu like you know i have to
keep practicing for example like a lot
of the emotion
like connecting with your emotions
vulnerability compassion self-compassion
uh
pre-gsb i was definitely very much
up here like post
consulting econ undergrad like i was
very analytical
and i think i started
opening up more to these things
i think it helped me
on the communication side when when
pitching lala
i remember getting the feedback that was
like
i'm hearing that you're excited about
this but
you're speaking like a consultant i was
like good point so when i'm talking
about la la i will let more of the
emotion come out
[Music]
compassion and self-compassion
super valuable especially
over the last two years both with myself
and the team and students and so on
so so both of those definitely helped
i forget from which classes but
at
the beginning of the pandemic we had to
make a really hard choice around do we
close a program and fly all the students
home or do we keep them and
hedge our beds and so on and i remember
this idea of
like at the end of the day if you're in
a leadership position you have to make
the final call you have to be decisive
kind of like what what i was saying but
at some point you just have to be
decisive make the call
but you can be inclusive you can
listen and include others um so remember
we we set ourselves a 24-hour timeline
to say we're gonna listen
to the students the parents the team
donors advisors everyone but
this time tomorrow we're making the call
uh in hindsight that probably saved us
from bankruptcy
um and then
it's connected to leadership and
entrepreneurship i think i i really came
out of the gsb having adopted the dna of
lean startup experimentation
trial and error prototyping
also of empowering the team to be the
innovators and
i think
we have come out of the pandemic but
we're still pandemic but we're stronger
now than before we have virtual programs
that we had never considered before a
lot of that were team innovations
um so but being very comfortable with
trying new things experimenting being
comfortable with some things not working
out
and again empowering the team to to
speak up take ownership innovate
collectively i think over time lead to
stronger teams better organizations and
so on so
um
[Music]
yeah i i think i credited the gsb with a
lot of them
listen thank you all i think we have
time for maybe one more question
and bringing together a couple
a couple questions that i see in the q a
um
a couple of our attendees are wondering
when is the right time
um
when
how did you know how did you all know
that it was the right time to pursue an
mba if if you did know or did you take
the plunge not knowing um
how did you know you were ready for the
experience
well i i think for me it was about
i had like to juggle two things like is
it the right moment for me is it right
moment for my daughter and and for me
it was sort of it just coincided that i
applied and i got to just be at the
average age which i think is 27 or 28 i
i entered the the gsb when i was 28
but i i started working when i was 22 so
i already had like six years of
experience and it just coincided with
with my daughter still being in
preschool so for me that was important
because i wanted her to be in elementary
school like right away where she was
going to be the whole elementary school
so
those two things combined like having
enough experience because i think
what we i had a few classmates who were
uh just out of out of undergrad and
maybe had taken one or two years uh off
and they had i undoubtedly had also a
very good experience but i i remember
them telling me like a few of them uh
telling me like i wish i had come a
little later so i could bring more to
the class so i could give more back
because i feel like i'm only getting and
i'm not i'm not returning
and i think that is sort of true like i
think you sort of need a certain amount
of not years but a certain amount of
experience to really be able to
contribute to the discussion um
that goes on in every class
um
for me
i remember
um
i was ready to submit my application and
then i asked myself okay
why the gsb
like why an mba why the gsb
i when i ask myself why now i didn't
have a good answer for myself um i had
done two years of consulting two years
at a non-profit
and i don't know why i had this
this idea of like two plus two plus two
was a good idea right um i was like on
if i if i leave this nonprofit now and i
graduate from the nba i will be under 30
with an mba like for some reason that's
a good thing to be
and for me
a couple of things
uh pushed me to
wait one more year
one was
that at this nonprofit i had built two
years of knowledge inside skills social
capital
so i felt like i could give more to that
non-profit if i stayed there one more
year or third year instead of just
leaving
and two i didn't have almost any
managerial experience um
so i i try to make sure i i had that
for at least one year pre-mba
i was at the gsb ages 28 30 so i was on
the slightly older side
um i feel like i got a lot more out of
it than if i had gone earlier
uh even now after three years running la
la i'm like i wish i could go now
uh i feel like i would get so much more
now just because
like you like i don't know you go
through a higher a class that touches on
hiring or a class that touches on firing
and now three years later i'm like
what did we what did we cover
um maybe i should have been a better
student um
[Music]
yeah in my case it was i guess i'm the
spectrum i applied when i was 23 to the
gsb so i was one of the young ones but i
started working at 20 in consultants i
had three years of experience but um for
me it was a sense of urgency to wanting
to do something for education in latin
america and coming back i grew up in a
low
socio-economic status of mexico and
coming back that people were getting
involved in crime there was a a lot of
i mean in corruption a lot of uh it was
very unsafe to live in the neighborhood
that i was and i was like why am i the
lucky one
living in houston having a great life
and that's when i was like i need to
find
a way to speed the
how can i get to a education leadership
position faster
and i identify that getting an mba at a
top business school combining with
education knowledge will get me there
faster so
that's what took me and i knew it was
the right time because
the problems that i was seeing in mexico
could not wait so i was like i need to
make this quick so that's when i decided
to apply i got accepted when i was 22 i
started when i was 24 and i don't regret
it i definitely felt that i learned a
lot but again i come from this idea that
i wanted to make things happen faster
and
it really helped me because i don't
think without the gsb i would have
become the executive director of the no
a non-profit this size that in singapore
mexico was
when i joined uh two years and a half
three years ago
you all so much for
being for your candor for
uh sharing so much of your journeys with
our audience um i will note regarding
the question about when
how do you decide when to apply
our community includes people with a
wide range of experiences and that
includes years of work experience
as alice mentioned some folks might have
a couple years of experience
some folks might have over a decade of
experience and all are welcome in our
application process and we think that
um
all of those experiences bring a
perspective that enriches our
educational environment
so thank you all again for sharing your
perspectives with us
um for attendees we're gonna throw a
poll out there so you can let us know
how we're doing these events are are all
about serving you so we would love to
get some of your feedback about how this
event has gone for you all
and thank you again for spending a
little bit of your day with us and take
care
thank you all so much
[Music]
you